de tronche une tronche retour de
vacances bonjour comment est ce que vous
allez j'espère que chez vous ça se passe
bien vous profitez soit des vacances
soit de l'été soit de l'automne ça
dépend à quel moment de vous allez
regarder cette vidéo alors moi je vous
fais une vidéo pour vous donner mon
retour sur le vivant x80 provigo c'est
pas forcément la marque la plus connue
en france dans une très grosse marque un
des leaders qui créent qui innovent
kaeppelin nouvelles technologies vous
allez voir que dans ce bus 80 pro il ya
aussi de la nouvelle technologie sont
précurseurs sont beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et c'est une marque qui
s'implantent doucement ses marques aime
prendre son temps qui aime faire les
choses bien comme il aime le dire ils
prennent le temps tout doucement alors
là il s'aggrave avec un tout nouveau
modèle cloud quelques mois maintenant
déjà gelé connu moi c'était qu'au mois
de juin speed up bêtise modèle
intéressant modèle chouette c'est
peut-être pas le smartphone de l'année
mais ils m'ont des nouvelles super
chouette ça permettra à plein de
personnes de mieux connaître de mieux
apprivoiser de mieux appréhender vivo et
de comprendre quelle histoire et nous
raconte est-ce que vous êtes prêts on se
parle aujourd'hui du vivo x80 propret on
y va go
alors regardez il est là j'arrive de
taper aussi fort ça c'est le x 80 pro
alors je vous l'avais déjà présenté
lorsqu'on était à berlin pour rendre
lancement officiel le x 80 prochain
smartphone qu'à la gueule il assez
massif et les quand même assez grand
c'est une belle bête envoyé tient dans
une main mais bon tout grosses paluches
à sera encore un petit peu mieux puis
pas d énormes paluches mais c'est quand
même un smartphone qui est quand même
assez proéminent il est néanmoins plutôt
pas mal on ne tient pas trop mal un tant
soit faut vraiment ne peut plus des
grosses mains pour bien bien bien le
tenir il est assez différenciant de par
son dos et de parts gros module photo
alors attendez moi je dis tout de suite
je les laisser traîner un petit peu dans
un sac à dos et il a marqué au dos alors
de toute façon les smartphones mieux
vaut venir les protéger au dos et mettre
des coques ça je voulais des années
plusieurs fois mais sinon moi je trouve
sympa j'aime bien ce dos alors là y'a un
côté un peu plus miroir qui va prendre
un peu plus de trace ici mais pour
autant je trouve un peu différent de ce
qu'on peut trouver sur le marché et ça
ça fait beaucoup de bien le smartphone
est élégant un très grand classique
après au niveau du design bon voilà ça
fonctionnera première chose que de venir
vous interpellez c'est ce que vous voyez
ici c'est à dire qu'en fait tout ce
passe au niveau du capteur d'empreintes
digitales normalement sur un smartphone
un peu classique quelqu'un connait un
capteur d'empreintes digitales c'est une
certaine zone sûre qu'elle va venir
poser votre doigt et déverrouiller vivo
ont une fois de plus innover sur ce gros
capteur d'empreintes digitales parce
qu'en fait toute la zone que vous allez
retrouver ici là c'est le capteur
d'empreintes digitales sas à plusieurs
bénéfices promis bénéfices lorsque vous
venez d'enregistrer votre doigt vous le
posez une fois sans vos smartphones à
plat comme ça et il a scanné toute
l'empreinte pas besoin d'appuyer plein
de fois tous les côtés peu tendre une
fois alors la configuration direz vous
c'est pas tout le plus relou parce qu'on
fait une fois et c'est terminé certes
mais c'est quand même pas mal et c'est
appréciable et le deuxième point qui est
intéressant c'est que comme ils ont un
très grand espace au niveau du capteur
d'empreintes digitales et bien ils sont
venus un peu subdiviser les espaces là
c'est la zone principale pour venir
déverrouiller donc vous posez votre
doigt sa déverrouille extrêmement
rapidement et vous arrivez là donc ça
c'est plutôt bien ça vous permet
également de faire d'autres trucs ça
vous permet de venir paramétrer votre
espace des capteurs d'empreintes
digitales pour mettre d'autres
raccourcis alors moi je vous ai mis un
facebook et youtube donc en fait vous
appuyer là vous voulez avec votre doigt
et ça vous emmène directement sur
l'application dont je trouve ça assez
marrant est assez malin alors après vous
venez régler tout ça directement dans
vos paramètres
ici vous venez d'en sécurité et dans
sécurité vous avez empreintes digitales
qui est situé juste là alors moi je vais
enregistrer deux empreintes vous venez
pour déverrouiller confidences et
gnagnagna zone de déverrouillage par
empreintes et là regardez c'est assez
marrant choisir en fait que la zone soit
grande soient petites ou grandes zones
plutôt pas mal c'est ce que j'ai déjà
fait ok le style d'animation vous voulez
voir parce qu'il ya différentes
animations à ce que vous venez de
déverrouiller bon voilà c'est du point
de détail mais je trouve ça assez rigolo
moi je les sais ça ok les actions
rapides et celles à regarder au moi j'ai
mis ici facebook youtube je peux me
remettre à la verticale je peux le
maître d'un côté je peux le maître de
l'autre je trouve ça pas mal alors par
défaut moi j'ai mis facebook youtube
parce que c'est des applis j'utilise
assez régulièrement permettre aussi à
votre téléphone votre agenda ou vie
normale ce que vous voulez vous
personnalisez vous choisissez les
applications que vous voulez donc ce
côté là est vachement pratique et c'est
là où l'innovation a vraiment un sens
parce que au-delà de l'austrian une fois
eh bien voyez ça permet de personnaliser
de faire réellement ce qu'on veut donc
ça une fois de plus c'est super bien et
puis ça montre vraiment ce que fait
vivre parce que alors je vous en donne
deux ou trois comme ça mais vive hausse
est aussi la boîte qui a créé la petite
caméra pop up vous savez la caméra qui
se met tout seul ce qui rentre et ça
c'est vivo qu'il l'a fait c'est eux qui
ont aussi créé le premier capteur
d'empreintes digitales basés ici donc
vive hausse une boîte qui innovent et
qui propose plein d'innovations que
ensuite d'hotman mounir utilisiez alors
j'imagine que derrière raison les
brevets et qu'ils encaissent des
quenottes marque vient intégrer ses
différentes fonctionnalités mais en tout
cas c'est bien celle assez marrant
autres trucs à venir connaître ici c'est
que derrière vous avez un revêtement
nice alors c'est pour toute la partie
photo vous avez un partenariat avec ice
est bien écrit ici bleus sur gris foncé
noir à peu près ça donc ok point aussi
relativement intéressant d'avoir salah
et puis dites avec le truc est vraiment
vraiment cool c'est ce très grand écran
vous retrouver sur ce smartphone c'est
un écran de
6,78 pouces et moi cet écran je trouve
pas mal alors attendez je sais tout le
monde n'aimera pas ça pourquoi lorsqu'il
est légèrement incurvé sur les côtés et
qu' il ya plein de gens qui n'aiment pas
les écrans incurvés qui veulent des
écrans droit moi cet écran incurvé une
plaie bien j'aime bien ça apporte de la
profondeur et je trouve ça assez joli
pendant plus une dalle ltp au alors le
ftp ou ça vous permettra quoi et place
permettra d'avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement variable au niveau de
votre dalle amoled ce qui fait vous
allez passer de je ne sais pas combien
de 120 air 60 hertz 90 heures en
fonction des besoins que vous allez
avoir ça va venir 61 ce que vous allez
lire scroller que vous allez venir
naviguer lorsque vous allez être sûr de
l'insta g sur différentes choses que
vous allez venir jouer à des jeux
également se sentir réellement et ça
vous apprendra beaucoup plus de fluidité
une meilleure expérience donc c'est un
écran qui est vraiment bien maîtrisé il
fonctionnera bien pour du gaming pour me
regarder des films des scènes entre
c'est vraiment toi j'ai beaucoup aimé
ici j'ai trouvé de super belle qualité
une très très jolie da ici résolution
plus w qhd plus enfin bref on a un truc
est très cool alors une fois de plus
c'est le point faible ici de ce
smartphone c'est que comme vous avez
déjà un très très bel écran même si ces
deux-là molex n'a pas consommé le plus
il ya quelques points qui sont un peu
faut faire un peu gaffe comme on est ici
sur du wqs des plus voyants au niveau de
la résolution de l'écran hop là si je
vais le pousser là j'avais mis en full
hd plus c'est pourquoi je l'aimé en full
hd plus parce qu'on double vécu hd + et
bien c'est bien consommer davantage
et je dirais que l'autonomie c'est un
peu le parent pauvre de ce smartphone
sur plusieurs raisons alors on a déjà un
processeur est quand même plutôt pas mal
c'est le ca dragon 8 de première
génération inconvénients de ce
processeur qualcomm c'est qui vient un
petit peu trop chauffé et lorsque vous
allez venir jouer à des jeux et que vous
passez un peu beaucoup de temps avec le
smartphone dans les mains que vous allez
vraiment sentir de la chance derrière et
ça peut être un moment un petit peu
inconfortable alors si vous mettez une
coque de protection la chauffe sentira
moins parce que la cob à venir faire son
rôle protecteur en tout cas et vous
protégera également le bout des doigts
alors attention ça ne craindra pas le
bout des doigts vous êtes vraiment
tranquille là dessus mais c'est un peu
l'inconvénient de ce smartphone à côté
de ça ce processeur lui permet d'avoir
beaucoup de performances en plus vous
avez 12 giga de ram donc vous avez un
vrai beau smartphone extrêmement
performant là dessus pour venir jouer
pour la fluidité pour tout ce que vous
voulez y a pas de souci maintenant on a
ce petit problème d'autonomie c'est pas
la meilleure autonomie du marché bien
vous ayez une batterie de 4700 millions
terreur et bien
non vous vire recharge à qu'une recharge
filaire de 80 watts donc ça ira très
vite il n'y a pas de souci mais si vous
n'avez pas votre bloc de charge avec
vous et si vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de venir le charger et bien
il se peut qu'à un moment vous soyez à
court de batterie alors une fois de plus
ça va dépendre de vous ou de vos usages
de ce que vous allez en faire si vous
désactivez tout si vous baissez la
résolution et si vous êtes tranquille
vous allez le garder un peu plus mais
par rapport à d'autres smartphones sur
le même segment l'autonomie si c'est pas
son point fort il faut le savoir en plus
de sa vie vaut nous a dit on vous met
une puce appelle la puce et l'avivo
s'est lavé en plus qui va permettre
d'augmenter d'améliorer l'autonomie la
fluidité la luminosité tout sachez
d'abord un soft autonomie alors
peut-être que si on avait passé depuis
ce serait vraiment une catastrophe bon
ok l'autonomie c'est à revoir c'est pas
le point fort ce smartphone à côté de ça
c'est pour vous l'autonomie c'est pas le
tout le plus important que vous avez
souvent la possibilité d'agir pas tout
le temps puis si vous avez la
possibilité de venir leur charge et de
temps en temps vous avez votre bloc de
charge avec vous vous en moquez n'a pas
de preuve d'autonomie donc on s'en fiche
sera un petit peu aux points à venir ici
à connaître c'est que l'expérience
logiciel c'est funtouch find out in
touch funtouch funtouch ne sais pas
comment le dr vous savez parce que comme
moi je navigue beaucoup entre
différentes expériences qu'on soit sûr
d'expérience les os différents
expérience android il ya un moment j'en
vois tellement j'en vois tellement de
tous les côtés que on se dit bon alors
attends c'est là qu'elle aboutisse à la
presse elle l'a été sa star c'est pas
mal on s'y repère c'est assez clair
regardez là je lui m'aide un peu plus un
peu plus là pour vous voyez c'est très
clair elles sont ces codes couleur femme
est vraiment se repérer très très
facilement effet dynamique pour des
animations et des convois dans les sous
menus tout de suite c'est un petit peu
plus austère parce qu'on n'a pas assez
différentes animations on a un peu des
petits tirer la voyez ils vous
permettent de partager de segmenter mais
ça pour m'envoyer ses ministres texte et
la liste de textes je la trouve un peu
imbitable ce menu là il est bien mais
c'est vrai quand on va nous faire plier
un peu plus en profondeur là où d'autres
marques font des choses un peu plus cool
et un peu plus lisible je trouve qu'il a
un côté un peu plus austère des convois
dans les sous menus voilà ça c'est le
truc un peu un peu négatif pour autant
ils ont une expérience qui est assez
complète on a plein de choses vous avez
également un mode ultra jeu tout ce qui
va bien en termes de sécurité la gestion
de vos comptes voilà c'est vraiment la
question du sous mon mieux je trouve
qu'il manque un petit peu de lisibilité
il faudrait ajouter des petits pictos
photographes des icônes faudrait rendre
un peu plus sexy mais dans l'ensemble
bons rails puis après vous savez sur la
même chose quand on a l'habitude d'être
sur cette expérience là qu'on est tout
le temps de sourire à ses repères et on
sait très bien l'utiliser en passons sur
différentes expériences avec celle là
pour moi c'est pas la plus claire dans
les sous menus le menu a bien bas c'est
une question de point de vue et
d'habitude alors il ya d'autres sujets
qui vachement important ici c'est toute
la partie photo je voulais montrer il ya
un partenariat avec zain au niveau des
optiques un très joli travail qui est
fait ici donc il ya un vrai beau boulot
qui est fait au niveau des photos pour
venir se situe très rapidement la chose
parce que vous n'êtes pas forcément
gardé la première vidéo vous avez vous
le voyez ici quatre capteurs vous avez
votre capteur principal votre grand
angle alors ça doit être celui là je
pense parce que je n'ai pas noté c'est
1,50 mégapixels vous avez un ultra
grand-angle de 48 mégapixels vous avez
une caméra portrait stabiliser en 12
mégapixels et puis vous avez un tel
objectif ici 8 mégapixels d'un zoom
optique x 5 qui va jusqu'à x 60 vous
allez voir que ça tout que je regrette
un petit peu c'était l'objectif je pense
qu'ils auraient pu aller beaucoup plus
loin améliorer le capteur matraques a
peur de meilleures qualités foncières de
meilleurs résultats en photo on va se
garder ça dans quelques instants et puis
vous avez bien évidemment un capteur
selphy qui est situé juste là ça c'est
du 30 2 mégapixels regardez le résultat
de toute façon il faut regarder les
photos pour s'en rendre compte il ya
plein de photos j'ai pris mon temps je
suis allé faire des photos dans plein de
différents endroits ça c'était lors du
lancement à berlin c'était plutôt pas
mal j'ai trouvé ça assez sympa sur la
photo de nuit comme ça l'ultra grand
tante très clairement la nuit on va pas
y aller mais de toute façon c'est pas
lié à ce smartphone dont tous les
smartphones sont les ultra grand-angle
on oublie c'est pas terrible mais je
trouvais que ce serait quand même plutôt
pas mal je vais bien cette ambiance art
après c'est berlin j'adore berlin faut
que la nuit c'est une ville qui est
magnifique avec des choses pas mal ce
qu'on va voir en fait c'est tout les
problèmes des éclairages et dès qu'il ya
un peu d'éclairage ça fout le bazar et
ça vous allez le voir va retrouver un
peu à droite à gauche c'est là où cet
appareil je trouve qu'il a certaines
limites quand même au niveau de la photo
nuit l'ultra grand temps qu'on n'oublie
offre un coucou à anne qui est qu'elle
avait pris la pose pour moi mais voilà
bon après c'est berlin j'adore tellement
cette ville que bon d'affirmer son
attachement très très très simple j'ai
fait d'autres photos il est un peu plus
jour on est ici à las vegas alors c'est
vrai que dans des conditions de bonne
luminosité la journée s'en sort vraiment
bien sûr le grand angle sur l' ultra
grand angle il fait le taff également et
on peut venir se rapprocher un petit peu
zoomer alors on va éviter d'aller
beaucoup trop loin parce qu'on va venir
perdre mais je trouve que malgré tout
alors on voit il ya tout un blues lice à
jacarei algorithmique est fait ici pour
vous sortir un résultat plus propre avec
un côté un peu plus nette bon voilà ça
c'est la lgo qui bosse derrière et qui
sont des choses qui sont pas des goûts
des gueux on va éviter le faux 60 parce
que ça aille pas terrible mais dans
l'ensemble je trouve qu'une bonne
gestion
de la lumière bonne plage dynamique dès
lors qu'on va pas venir gratouiller est
trop trop loin en venant vous mais avec
des zooms totalement fantaisistes il
sera de toute façon c'est le cas de tous
les smartphones même la frime onstreet
voyait le taf effet dès qu'il ya
beaucoup de lumière de toute façon il
s'est très très bien bossé ce smartphone
alors la voyez c'est le problème du zoom
poussé beaucoup trop loin j'ai voulu
aller chercher loin c'était sur un
concert des eagles étaient au hellfest
et la slaj bien voyez c'est ce qui fait
la gueule se lâche on peut pas venir
photographier aussi loin donc quand je
vous dis que le zoom jusqu'à x 60 c'est
de la fiche technique c'est pour vous
faire rêver mais regardez là axl rose va
y est alors déjà qu'aujourd'hui quand
même un peu m'enfler axa le rhône là on
va plus grand chose et donc bon voilà
c'est un peu le truc on va éviter de
venir ajouté beaucoup trop loin c'est
pas fait pour ça très clairement c'est
pas fait pour ça allait je vous passe
les guns parce que de toute façon ça va
être un beat ap comme ça et voyez là
alors je n'étais pas à zoomer autant
mais c'est quand même beaucoup zoomer et
même là il avait franchement de mâlain
franchement franchement c'était pas
évident pour les autres photos dans des
conditions de faible luminosité toujours
au hellfest et vous allez voir ça fait
un peu plus dur alors là sauf que c'est
pas mal là bon ça fait le taff aussi à
peu près ça ça fonctionne aussi à peu
près voyez on voit bien dans le ciel est
les petits lasers et c'est assez jolie
miss quand on a vraiment un éclairage de
face que la sip regarder la vie
complètement noyé il a de l'éclairage de
phase iib on a tous les côtés là il n'en
peut plus le bout de sa vie même là la
voyez là dès qu'il a ça la voilà là il
est un peu à genoux et là la voix n'en
parlons même pas mais ça c'est un ultra
grand-angle donc ça n'est pas surprenant
et on n'en voudra pas d'envoyer là ils
en chient fortement et là tout seul
problème de photos nuit ça c'était pas
mal je trouvais ça assez joli c'est
aussi relativement bien éclairé il faut
le reconnaître les voyez là ici là voilà
ça c'est pas terrible là non plus voyez
bon on sort des choses mais on voit
quand même qu'il est vraiment en
souffrance un peu tous les côtés et
juste cette photo que j'aime bien vous
avez cet éclairage qu'avant dans une
belle ambiance ça c'est sorti de fps
c'est vraiment un truc que j'adore
d'autres photos je vous ai fait à paris
pour vous montrer également bon bah
voilà c'est plutôt pas mal c'est pas le
photophone du siècle ça ces photos nuit
en vacances au mexique
alors c'est le truc me reprocha ce
smartphone comme à beaucoup de
smartphones c'est que les photos nuit
veulent qu'ils fassent jour on doit tous
voir aujourd'hui sur les smartphones
pour photo nuit alors que non il faut
pas tout voir on peut pas tout voir il y
avait un nuage là ça me l'a trop
éclaircies c'est trop blanc ça
fonctionne pas mais une fois de plus à
part que eux qui veulent faire ça il ya
beaucoup de marques on arrive à yale a
sorti un truc et qui est assez rigolo
j'aime beaucoup ça parce que l'on à côté
un peu cubique cassé avec cette espèce
de couloir qui tourne on sait pas où on
va j'aime beaucoup cette photo je trouve
ça très joli et voyez il fait nuit noire
et le travail algorithmique fait qu'on
pourrait croire qu'il fait jour pourtant
on voit bien l'ombre là et il ya un truc
qui est pas dégueu mais que je trouve
que ne fonctionne pas voilà pour ce que
je voulais vous montrer au niveau de la
photo sur ce smartphone c'est dans
l'ensemble pas mal mais il faut que la
lumière et il voyait des cas beaucoup de
lui mais a tout de suite ça fonctionne
très bien le capteur principal est très
très jolis seins qu'elle luttera contre
anglet un peu en dessous mais bon c'est
pas surprenant et une fois de plus c'est
des choses qu'on a l'habitude de voir
sur les smartphones et même la caméra de
celle fille avec sa tronche en mode
vacances eh ben je trouve que elle fait
le taff et elle fait plutôt bien le taf
et ça c'est un très très bon point il
faut vraiment bien le préciser autre
élément que je trouve un petit peu en
dessous c'est la partie audio est compté
vous allez voir vous avez en fait ici de
aux fleurs haut parleurs principal ici
deuxième haut parleurs ici et comme
beaucoup de smartphones il va avoir un
tendance est assez déséquilibré c'est à
dire que la bombe à celui de l'iphone
offre d'envoi du songe pour pas de tuer
marche bien mais là on a un vrai
déséquilibre ici et avec lui a lancé
voilà là là
là ça manque de crèches et comme
beaucoup de smartphones je trouve que ça
casse un peu l'expérience il n'y a pas
beaucoup de smartphones qui me
surprennent a aujourd'hui acquis à asus
avec son rock funk il ya une vraie
expérience stéréo pour que lui fait
vraiment pas un coin et c'est un peu
dommage quoi bon je vais pas lui jeter
la pierre puisqu'un d'autres si vous
voulez une bonne expérience audio je
vous conseille d'apprendre des écouteurs
là vous avez d'ubuntu 5.2 ça marche bien
aucune prise jack un nilan il a donc on
va pas venir se brancher en prise
directe voir ça c'est un petit point de
détail me direz vous mais il peut pour
certains avoir son importance d'ailleurs
dit moi si c'est le cas pour vous autre
élément qui est assez intéressant ici
c'est toute la partie vidéo qui était
mise en avant le partenariat l'exercent
et compagnie je trouve que dans
l'ensemble c'est un plutôt un bon
vidéophone je vous montre quelques
petites vidéos ça c'est un truc que j'ai
filmé à las vegas je trouve à 16 bien
stabilisé ce smartphone donc vous le
tenez à la main vous venez filmer ça
bouge pas trop ça vraiment bien alors
après éviter de venir nous mais parce
que franchement la qualité est pas là
mais dans l'ensemble vous arrivez à
faire des trucs sont pas des goûts des
gueux r d sur un concert des eagles je
trouve que ces sables alors on peut
venir une fois plus on va éviter
d'autres zones et on peut venir un petit
peu fou mais si on souhaite bon attendez
je vous montre un autre truc regardez où
ça pas mal alors faut que j'arrête de
venir mais je trouve ça pas là je trouve
que le résultat quand même mais là
lorsque vous le prenez que vous ne venez
pas où mais vous avez une qualité qui
est quand même relativement correct
alors après on fait un truc qui est
assez marrant et une fois de plus c'est
dans l'idée ici de toute l'innovation
pour me retrouver au niveau de votre
vidéo c'est à dire qu'en fait vous avez
un truc est extrêmement bien stabilisé
que vous avez ici l'ultra stabilisation
l'ultra et la ligne horizontale alors la
ligne horizontale en fait c'est assez
marrant pourquoi parce que vous allez
prendre votre smartphone va pouvoir
tourner votre smartphone en fait vous
avez à guînes ball à l'intérieur ce qui
fait que l'image restera toujours droite
donc si vous êtes comme ça que vous
bouger un peu on aurait absolument aucun
problème vous êtes sur quelque chose
dans laxe et ça c'est assez marrant ou
autant lorsque vous venez faire ça vous
êtes uniquement en full hd et pas dans
autre chose parce que si vous passez à
autre chose et bien vous n'avez plus le
ligne de l'horizon elle part et ça c'est
tout qui est un peu ballot c'est à dire
que moi je trouve cette innovation
effectivement voyons pas cela en 1080p
eh ben elle est marrante mais si vous
voulez monter plus haut bien vous la
perdez donc ça c'est bien il faut venir
améliorer la copie pour que ce soit
réellement intéressant pour qui est
vraiment un usage pour que ça puisse
servir à quelqu'un alors après on peut
venir filmer en flat et compagnie si
vous voulez bon ok ok ok donc pour moi
ce smartphone il est quand même pas mal
fichu il est pas mal fichu sur plusieurs
points sur l'écran qui est super bien
sûr l'innovation prend à venir retrouver
sur la photo de plein jour il a beaucoup
de performances il a du vrai point
faible au niveau de l'autonomie c'est
pas ouf il vient quand même chauffé donc
si vous voulez jouer pendant de longues
sessions 100 m de kock de protection ça
va bien vous chauffez le bout du doigt
donc pratique en hiver mais les ténè
noah envie de ça donc c'est un bon
smartphone symbole haut de gamme vivo
propose un produit qui super cool à 1299
euros maintenant pour autant à 1299
euros est ce que c'est le smartphone
qu'il faut venir acheter aujourd'hui
sous android j'en suis pas extrêmement
convaincu des smartphones avec des seins
dragon 8 de première génération y en a
quelques-uns catalogue et sont tous
plutôt très bien fait pour autant ils
n'ont pas tous des partenariats avec
zite mais vous retrouverez des
smartphones avec de très jolis capteur
photo qui seront meilleurs en photo nue
qui auront une meilleure autonomie donc
c'est aujourd'hui une très jolie copie
se vivent au x 80 pro c'est pas
forcément le smartphone que j'aimerais
recommandé à ce tarif-là moins cher je
trouverais intéressant je voudrais ok on
peut y aller sauter sur un tarif aux
alentours des 700 et 800 mhz agréable et
ok ok après il faut vraiment connaître
il ya beaucoup d'innovations cette
caméra guillemoles aller là il ya plein
de choses très très cool mais bon par
rapport à ce qu à la concurrence
aujourd'hui je trouve quand même qu'il
ya certains points faibles qui font qu
on va pas se dire que ça le flagship
qu'on va venir acheter autre que j'ai
trouvé extrêmement intéressant pourquoi
parce que l'innovation est là parce que
vivo est là parce que j'ai hâte de voir
ce que proposera vivo dans les temps à
venir on reviendra ça de plus près
attendant vous dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que ce smartphone pourrait
vous tentez est ce que cela sous entend
que vous auriez vous envie d'acheter
est-ce que vivo c'est une marque qui
vous botte qui voyais pas ce que vous la
connaissiez au wynn non pas du tout pas
comment vous marquez tout ça juste en
bas en commentaire et puis s'il vous
fait de l'oeil et bien moi je vous mets
un petit lien en bas de la description
pour vous faire plaisir voilà je vous
embrasse pour lé soin de vous et surtout
à très bientôt prêt ciao
[Musique]